there's no bad time for pride wars it's
just so good
um and uh i think it should be in the
criterion collection you know it's it's
and i think films
that everyone should be studying did it
make the afi list this year i didn't see
it there
but it sounds like from today's review
it really should have been on there
yeah i wish the reviewers were as kind
as drew barrymore
i absolutely love it and also you guys
both
have very prolific careers in that you
both have your podcast
[ __ ] sesh and how did this get made you
collaborate with each other you
write you act you work with fellow
comedians
i mean this is not only looks like
so much fun from the outside looking in
but what you put out into the world is
necessary i
need comedy it is my
it is my breakfast lunch and dinner it
is my lexapro i'm on that too but i
love i need to at 20 milligrams right
now i
could stick a fork in my leg i wouldn't
listen i'm on a cocktail right now
that's
keeping me keeping a smile on my face
well that's what you do with your guys's
work do you have so much fun making it
to put it out there
we do honestly i think yes
i mean i do such important work you know
on my podcast talking about the real
housewives and poignant work
in that sphere and but i think getting
to work with june my whole career and
trying to write not to be
cheesy but truly trying to write stories
for women and just entertain good
old-fashioned entertain especially in
these times
i i do love to do that and love to make
people laugh and i do think we need it
bad in my will butrin you know we need
it
drew you should just put on like the
chiron instead of saying like june and
casey it should just say the doses of
antidepressants we're all on
um i do think that comedy is so
important
and my you know casey i have been best
friends since we were 18 we've known
each other since freshman year of
college
and since
yeah that's just about five years ago
now i mean we just have fun together and
bride wars was the first job we ever had
in the entertainment industry yeah
june i'm so sorry to cut you off my
first job was a bloated stomach
commercial
i'm sorry i forgot about that you know
what
i don't think there's anything that's
more
important to me in my life in fact
the very first you know segment of this
show
that i am so lucky to do i asked
my two girlfriends to come join me lucy
lou
and cameron diaz like my money is where
my mouth is
my girlfriend who i get to do things
with
who i get to laugh with live life with
love with be honest make jokes create
with
that's the dream and when i look at you
guys
outside i just am marveling at what
you're doing i'm a huge fan girl
and i just am cheering you on and i want
to be in your club any time you'll have
me
and thank you for saying that i
appreciate you saying
that well i think june you
could probably sell anybody anything
because the way that you spoke about
womanhood and being alive and being a
mom
and trying to get it all done was so
relatable and inspiring
that it was the perfect segue into the
jane club and this is the perfect segue
into the fact that
we have um four moms in our virtual
friends and family while our vffs
with two bffs who are going to get
um memberships uh gwinnett tamika
gina and erin um and june is gifting you
each six
months worth of memberships
oh my gosh i'm so excited i'm so
thrilled that you all are joining us
there i
also love i need to be deep and
meaningful
and i need to lighten it up so i want to
talk about the real
and what makes it all worth it and it
sounds like the jane club is the perfect
place
to do that june and casey thank you so
much
you can catch casey on showtime's black
monday
and check out june's amazing amazing
organization the jane club and also
you're still on grayson frankie i'm
gonna tell you
netflix doesn't mess around even a
successful show they'll kill it after
three seasons
you're going into season seven well
that's really yes we well we are one of
their first comedies
um i'm so proud to be in a show that
talks about women aging also
in uh in all of their in in their
you know in their hilariousness their
sexuality their
friendship um it's really it's such a
special show
well maybe you and casey should do a
show about how you both sold your soul
to the devil to look younger by the day
yeah thank you i'm on it thank you well
i'll be thinking about
you guys tomorrow morning when i take my
[Music]
dose